in the wake of the police killings of
george floyd and brianna taylor last
year tarana burke founder of the metoo
movement and new york times best-selling
author brene brown
think of those two together teamed up to
co-ed and co-edit a new book it's called
you
are your best thing love that title
vulnerability shame resilience
and the black experience the collection
of essays from black men
and women is about their lives in
overcoming racism
writer austin channing brown is one of
the voices in the book
her essay this joy i have reflects on
heartache and hope
she read some excerpts from her piece
just for us
[Music]
racism is the silent stalker always
willing
to ring joy from our lives this level of
foreboding joy is not in our heads
it's in the evidence of our experience
when my husband is in the car i do not
fear only the possibility of an accident
but the possibility of a police officer
harassing him
maybe even taking his life
we have learned
that the only thing white supremacy
would love more than taking our lives
is for the lives we have to be
diminished
less than human filled with despair
containing only fear the joy of
blackness
persists our joy is in the legacy
of all that our ancestors have done for
us
our joy is being able to participate in
that legacy now
our joy is in having left a mark in the
world
being able to say i was here
[Music]
when i look into my little boy's eyes
and wonder if his life will mirror
trayvon's
i silently thank trayvon martin for his
life
i will love him harder and in this
become
softer i will be vulnerable
open to being hurt because i trust that
my joy in him
cannot be taken away
beautiful picture of her with her little
baby boy tarana burke and brene brown
join us now toronto we should say
also recently signed a production deal
with cbs studios
i didn't know that toronto so i'll just
say welcome to the family
and it's good to see you both this
morning those essays guys are so
powerful you know i pulled out a couple
laverne cox who says
she never leaves home without her armor
up i like that
professor mark lamont hill says therapy
is a staple of his emotional diet
in the beginning it was a badge of shame
and now it's key to survival
i mean you just have one powerful
reading after another after another so
tarana i want to start with you
what were you trying to accomplish with
the essays what were you looking for and
why did you think renee brown would be
the perfect partner for this
well brene and i are friends and i had
many discussions with her about some of
these topics
and when this came up when george floyd
and brianna taylor hit us like a ton of
bricks last summer
i was really sad and i watched a lot of
black people around me
who were also sad and felt a range of
emotions but nobody really were tapping
into
what we were feeling and as much as they
were asking how can we be better people
how can we be anti-racist and things
like that
and so i wanted to talk to brene about
you know how her work had helped me but
also about how
we can contribute to this moment and you
know
true to form she was very very very much
down with it as soon as i asked the
question were you reluctant to ask her
i was very reluctant why i mean i didn't
know our friendship had
been well because our friendship had
just been a friendship right we didn't
really talk about work and things of
that nature
and i was i was saying to her i think
your work is important for black people
but i also think that
i can't really find myself in your work
right away and i want to i want to
change that
and that's a big thing to say to
somebody about their body of work and
also it's a test of a friendship
so renee tarana just said you were all
in were you hesitant at first yourself
no this is something i've been grappling
with for a really long time
and because i had always had
incredibly diverse samples i knew that
what needed to change was the telling of
the stories that
brought the data to life i knew the data
were representative of large groups of
people but i use a lot of my own stories
and i thought
how i don't want people to have to work
hard to find themselves
in the work and so when she teed up the
idea
of a collaboration i think my answer was
a heck yes
or some version of that yeah but i
understand at one point you said should
a white person be talking about this
how do we navigate that is that our
conversation
yes because i was like i said look you
can have the data you i can support it i
can help but do you
do we want to code do you want me to
co-edit this with you and she's like
yeah you're you're the expert in this
area and i said
i i'm white and she's like yeah i'm
clear
i get it yeah
but i thought maybe we can do this in a
way that really models what co-creation
should be around um and as long as there
were some stipulations that
lived experience has to always trump
academic experience
she needed to take lead authorship yeah
i did think that was interesting
incredible project i did think it was
interesting when you say you know
uh life experience always trumps
academics and tarana i've heard you say
that vulnerability
is a word we all know but it's a
different experience when you talk to
black people
than when you talk to white people what
do you mean
absolutely you know brene talks about a
story in the book where she's
feeling vulnerable because she's in the
store with her daughter and her
daughter's being silly
and you know when we compare that to
what my experience could be
in the store with my daughter and i
could be stopped for shoplifting or i
feel vulnerable
in a different way because of my race
and because of how people perceive me
because of my race
and so when you talk to me about being
vulnerability as a pathway to a
wholehearted life
that feels scary to me because i don't
know what vulnerability
how that's going to affect me you know
in the world
it's a very different experience for for
black people and brene i've heard you
say that racism is trauma
what do you mean by that and how does
that connect to vulnerability
yeah i think one of the greatest
casualties of trauma
is trauma pulls from us
the ability willingness the space to be
vulnerable i mean you see this um you
know
if i see this when i work with vets i
see this when i work with people who've
been through violent crimes like you're
wanting to me
you want me to take the armor off i've
seen what that looks like but
i think what we don't understand is that
racism
persistent dehumanization that's trauma
as well
and so it's really important to
understand
that safety emotional safety
physical safety are prerequisites
for vulnerability and we all have a
responsibility to create
that environment because just because
you're black or you've gone through
trauma doesn't
mean that you need less vulnerability in
your life
um to know intimacy and trust and
creativity and innovation
but it means it's harder to come by
because we don't have
the safety what i thought that you both
captured so beautifully in the book
is about humanity it's not a story we
often hear about black and brown people
one of the strongest essays is from you
tarana burke we're out of time so people
have to get the book
where you talk about for the first time
having a stroke
it's very very powerful and i'm glad
you're okay glad you're okay
tarana burke and brene brown we thank
you both you are your best thing goes on
sale tomorrow
wherever you like to buy your books
you're watching cbs this morning